Intro
There's never been a better time for fans
of blockbuster movies, with more and more
movies raising the stakes, raising the budgets,
and competing to top the box office.
Some massive movies are on the way, which
means more behind the scenes secrets any movie
buff will want to know in our latest rapid
fire dose of trivia to Know Your Movies: 30
Mind Blowing Facts About New Movies.
Suicide Squad
Batman appearing the movie makes perfect sense,
given most of the villain's come from his
line of comic books.
But Ben Affleck will actually make history
as the first actor to play Batman for two
different directors.
The live action Harley Quinn is sporting a
new costume.
But according to star Margot Robbie, the costume
department actually made versions of her famous
jester suit, and the skirt and corset made
famous in the Batman: Arkham series.
They didn't make the cut, but there's always
the sequels!
Wonder Woman
Fans got their first look at the Wonder Woman
cast thanks to a photo in Batman V Superman
- but the connections don't end there.
Look closely in Wonder Woman and you'll be
able to catch surfeit Zack Snyder playing
a soldier
The similarities between DC's Wonder Woman
and Marvel's Thor are obvious.
But things got weird when actors Liam Hemsworth
and Alexander Skarsgard were considered for
Steve Trevor - Liam's brother plays Thor,
and Skarsgard's father plays his close friend.
Weird.
Beauty & The Beast
Never underestimate nostalgia: in its first
24 hours on YouTube, the trailer for this
film clocked over 91 millions views, smashing
the records set by Captain America: Civil
War and even Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
The movie is famous for its unforgettable
songs, but when the director went through
auditions he surprised each actor by having
them sing "Hakuna Matata" from The Lion King
instead.
According to him, it was just to confuse them.
Who says directors can't have some fun?
X-Men: Apocalypse
The movie finally sees star James McAvoy shave
his head to match Patrick Stewart, but fans
might miss another detail: his wheelchair
is the exact one used by Stewart in the original
X-Men films, bringing the series full circle.
Stan Lee teased that his trademark cameo in
Apocalypse would be something special, and
it is - he doesn't appear alone, but alongside
his wife Joan of fifty years.
How's that for romantic?
To get the villain's voice as inhuman as needed,
ator Oscar Isaac was brought in to re-record
all his dialogue, with a bass mic on one cheek,
and a bass drum mic on the other, with all
three mixed together in post.
Captain America: Civil War
In the movie, Falcon gets a new gadget in
the form of a recon drone called Redwing.
It's a more believable version of his pet
bird from the comics, which he could use to
scan the battlefield telepathically.
The studio made sure to show off star Chris
Evans biceps holding back a helicopter in
marketing, but the reason audiences had never
seen something like it is because of how unnatural
a pose it is in practise.
So unnatural Evans ended up suffering some
injuries to his arms as a result.
It's not an optical illusion: Captain America's
tshirts really are too small for him, on purpose,for
obvious reasons.
But over the course of filming, they have
to get even smaller, since star Chris Evans
will always lose weight and size due to the
rigorous schedule.
The Avengers: Infinity War
The movie will be action packed, but audiences
will also get to see it all in IMAX, since
it's the first no-documentary to be filmed
entirely in the format.
Fans got the first glimpse of the Infinity
Gauntlet in Odin's trophy room, but when the
one belonging to Thanos was the other hand,
they thought the studio had made a mistake.
But Marvel Boss Kevin Feige shot it down,
confirming there is more than one - hopefully
for a good reason.
Warcraft
Although some members of the cast have admitted
to be completely addicted to the online game,
star Travis Fimmel claims he had never actually
heard of the global sensation when he took
the job.
Typical Alliance.
Ninja Turtles: Out of The Shadows
Believe it or not the first version of the
movie didn't include fan favorite Casey Jones.
It was only when producer Michael Bay insisted
he be worked into the plot that the filmmakers
came up with a solution.
Fate took over from there: not only was Arrow
star Stephen Amell able to find time to play
the part, but he literally went from wrapping
Arrow season 3 to filming Turtles the next
day.
Finding Dory (Pixar)
Although over a decade has passed since Finding
Nemo, the sequel is only set six months later.
That meant a new voice actor was needed for
Nemo, since the original actor is now 22.
Feel old yet?
The movie originally followed some marine
life in a SeaWorld-esque Park, but after Pixar
executives saw the 2013 documentary Blackfish,
the story was changed to remove some questions
of animal cruelty.
Independence Day: Resurgence
An Independence Day sequel was actually feedlot
and paid for following the original, which
would have followed Will Smith's character's
stepson fighting aliens in space.
But writer Dean Devlin didn't like his work,
and actually returned the payment.
His character may be level headed, but Jeff
Goldblum was anything but while filming.
Aside from singing songs to his castmates
and demanding harmonies, he would even pass
out plays for the cast to perform between
takes I'm an effort to pass the time without
getting bored.
That's actually not even surprising.
Star Trek Beyond
It was long rumored that the first draft of
Star Trek 3 included an on screen reunion
of the original Kirk and Spock.
But while the studio waited to see if Shatner
would agree, Leonard Nimoy passed away, and
creative changes meant a completely new story
would be told.
How's this for weird: every single Star Trek
villain in the rebooted series is now ALSO
a Marvel movie hero.
Eric Bana played The Incredible Hulk, Benedict
Cumberbatch is playing Doctor Strange, and
Idris Elba plays Heimdall, Gatekeeper of Asgard
in Marvel's Thor series (alongside Chris Hemsworth,
who played Kirk's father).
What are the odds?
Doctor Strange
Actor Mads Mikkelson being cast as the villain
makes him the third man to portray a version
of Hannibal Lecter before joining a Marvel
movie.
Brian Cox first played the role in Manhunter
before joining X-Men, and Anthony Hopkins
made him famous before joining the Thor series.
The Disney ownership may play a bigger part
in Doctor Strange that you'd think.
While the magic has been said to draw on The
Matrix and Harry Potter, the cinematographer
turned to Disney's Fantasia for the visual
flourishes.
Fantastic Beasts
Author JK Rowling claimed to be done with
Harry Potter's world when the movie series
ended.
But when the president of the studio took
her to lunch, they walked away with a new
trilogy in the works, and Rowling claiming
it never would have happened without his pitch.
Must have been a good lunch.
Rowling has claimed that there's no overlap
between Fantastic Beasts and Harry Potter,
but thanks to one Easter egg in the Prisoner
of Azkaban, Newt Scamander did, indeed walks
the halls of Hogwarts during Harry's years.
Even though he was technically dead.
OR WAS HE.
Rogue One
Since the movie is set before the original
Star Wars, Rogue One's costume designer has
hinted that fans looking closely may spot
some of the original costumes made for the
1977 film, back in action.
Fans will finally get to see a younger version
of Mon Mothma, the leader of the Rebels played
by Genevieve O'Reilly.
But the actress played the part already - all
her scenes were simply cut out of the prequel
trilogy in editing.
It wasn't a Hollywood screenwriter or George
Lucas who thought up the premise of the movie,
but John Knoll, the ILM visual effects supervisor
who worked on the speckle editions and prequels.
When he started to think of spinoff storied
he'd like to see told, the result was a 20
minute pitch that became Rogue One.
So that’s our list of 30 awesome facts about
some of today’s biggest blockbuster hits.
What other fun stories or secrets have you
heard?
What big movies are you most excited for?
Let us know in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!